but I mean that's my thing Bill Maher
said something about people watching
comic book movies everybody flipped out
I said something about adults not
celebrating Halloween I said hey if you
gotta wear like an edgy Halloween
costume if that's your only way to be
why don't you give the holiday back to
children because that's who it was for
I'm let's go go and it was not really
directed and everybody was dressing up
it was kind of directed at the people
that are gonna get fired because they
went to a party dressed as a twin towers
I'm like well I can do that I'm a
comedian if you if you're if you're a
kindergarten teacher maybe hold hold off
on that it is what it is you know if you
want to go as a Korean person I'm not
for the cultural appropriation I really
don't care what you dress up as but
maybe in this climate it's not smart to
go as a Guatemalan I don't know what
some of these people do there so I just
tweeted like I was ok give Halloween
back to children don't dress up buy a
house get a job whatever people went not
it was the most controversial thing I've
ever said telling people to not telling
adults to not wear a costume think of
everything I've said the country is run
by demons they're sucking the energy out
of children the country is run by crime
families that murder that sell drugs to
traffic and human beings and what really
upset people as I said why don't you not
dress up in a costume
that's what really got people it's like
this Disney World article flip people
the [ __ ] out because somebody suggested
that maybe they give it up give the give
this child like what like that's a
problem with Disney worlds like all the
people there like approach the world
with childlike wonder
oh it's childlike why I feel like a kid
again I just feel like a kid don't don't
feel like a child there's a time to be a
chop and here's another one and this is
gonna really get people and we'll do
this one we're gonna do this one by the
way and we're gonna get out of here
folks you're not gonna like it
are you ready man you are not gonna like
this one
this one's gonna be this one's gonna be
one that people get really angry about
are you ready
prepare beasts take a seat I imagine
many of you are I imagine many people
aren't listening to this on the
elliptical I could be wrong the time to
smoke marijuana is in your late teens
and early to mid twenties after that it
should be very rare
it should not be all the time for most
people and don't give me like well Rogan
I did read that guy has a Constitution
you will never have yeah you want to get
yeah that guy's got three jobs he's
running up and down hills he could do
whatever the [ __ ] he want don't use an
example of like the for people that are
succeeding in life he's one of five
people that are doing well don't use
that example get real [ __ ] losers
come at me with a okay the weed everyday
folks not a good look
not a good look not to move not the move
is there anything more fun to be in
seventeen or eighteen or nineteen
getting high called you Taco Bell
laughing your ass off okay here's where
that's less fun your late 30s it is not
as fun and many of you were angry at me
but you know I'm right
I'm not a perfect person I get it I go
to talk about sober that's unforgivable
that is I mean I go sober thirty
five-year-old sober person will eat Taco
Bell that is in and of itself a crime it
should be against the law but cut it out
with the babes the weed you know
everybody's doing a high all the time
folks things are coming you're not gonna
want to be high for them you're gonna
want to be
uber when it comes you know what's
common